hey Johnny Depp's an eccentric cartoon
version of himself that's weird I've
never seen that before in the past ten
years Mordecai Mordecai is a movie about
Mordecai played by Johnny Depp he's a
really eccentric British art dealer
slash entrepreneur and he's looking for
a painting criminals are looking for him
thinking he has a painting he's helping
Ewan McGregor who's a cop and they're
all looking for a penny just think of
snacks well instead of a diamond it's a
painting instead of a bunch of people it
focuses on one guy named Mordecai played
by Johnny Depp and it's twice as crazy
as snatch but not half as interesting as
snatch I had a point in this movie
you're like am i watching a live-action
cartoon is it supposed to be a
live-action cartoon I really mean
cartoon not just because Johnny Depp
indeed absolutely 150 percent once again
plays a cartoon but there's one see
where he's getting shot at in his other
guys like this shooting at you in the do
get shot it goes Blau is like the
shooting at me Nelson boo boo boo boo
looks like you got killed but he died
like a cartoon what dies is it a cartoon
that's the conflicting messages movie
gives you is like is it live-action is
it supposed to be a live-action cartoon
is it real is it reality is it not is it
grounded in reality it's it's mordechai
which could be interesting but this
movie frustrates me it frustrates me in
the way that my school teachers told me
I frustrate them like they openly were
like you frustrate me because you could
be more as a student than what you are
you have this potential that you don't
use and maybe they told that all the
kids that's what some of them told me
they were like you frustrate me because
you have more potential than you're
using that's Mordecai's what this movie
is it's like if this movie focused up
and found it's tried it would actually
be kind of fun but this movie never
actually becomes as fun as the movie
tries to be you feel like Johnny Depp
phones it in is like fishing or here's
another roll I'm gonna do and is this
I'm gonna do the same [ __ ] over and over
and over again I'm gonna be Jack Sparrow
or an eccentric guy of some sort and I'm
gonna be the richest [ __ ] actor ever
and I get it works for him I were him I
wouldn't change [ __ ] either I'd be like
how many people out there own a spot of
land surrounded by an ocean yeah none of
you I do I'm Johnny guy yeah I do I do
that but as I'm on YouTube and I'm here
too you know who tell you what I think
about a movie I guess I guess I'm here
to [ __ ] about it the movie act
he does find its stride too little too
late in the movie in the last part of
the movie the movie actually ends up
Mordechai goes to LA and seeing this
uppity British art dealer deal with Los
Angeles was actually pretty cool it was
good it was funny it worked for the
movie made me sit back again with the
wasted potential and I was like why
didn't they do this for the whole movie
seeing that fish-out-of-water scenario
with the right character in the right
location it works for a movie so when I
see it in the last act of a movie that's
bored the [ __ ] out of me so far I'm like
there it is why why am I just getting
this now so Mordecai for Johnny Depp is
nothing new you've seen him play this
role a hundred times before in the past
15 years of his career it's messy for
the first two-thirds of the movie the
last third is actually where it focuses
up and you're like there's the stuff
it's not enough to save the movies on
the end I'm gonna say you're not gonna
remember Mordecai in t-minus a couple
days yep already forgot man what a
weekend it's okay if you spend this
weekend at home because there's nothing
good coming out in theaters this weekend
I'm here for you at Jeremy John's that
was shameless that's completely
shameless all right so your favorite
eccentric crime heist movie I don't know
if that's too specific I feel like it's
not I feel like there's enough of that
to ask so what is your favorite whatever
it is comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more